all right this story is sort of
mind-boggling California man sided and
handcuffed because he was eating a
sandwich on a BART train station
platform he is now getting an apology
so the dust-up was caught on video last
week at the Pleasant Hill station near
San Francisco Tacoma you single because
you're eating it's against the law right
there's a rule there it's about this
book cleanliness in the station
supposedly but right so here's what
happened Bart says Stephen Foster
refused to present the officer with his
ID and cursed at him the transit agency
faced mounting backlash over the
encounter so yesterday marks general
manager Bob Powers issued a statement
apologizing he said in part our concern
with eating is related to the
cleanliness of our stations and systems
I apologized to mr. foster our writers
employees and the public you know what
take on litter if you want to but a guy
eating a sandwich that's called
breakfast you don't want somebody eating
but but putting them in handcuffs
reading a sandwich and then the video
shows multiple police officers called it
in so more cops showed up for a guy
holding the same try to give up the
sandwich that's stories a person of
color he appears to be eating bread just
doing normal stuff going to my apartment
building
selling lemonade having a picnic at the
barbecue I mean it's just that just
seems to be another example of that very
first that officer with a straight face
you know what are you doing here it's
illegal you can't have it you can't be
eating also they sell food in the train
station yes well there's a note there